hey youtubers it's Charlie so this
week's agents of shield made a huge call
back to the Howling Commandos filled in
a lot of Garrett Anne Ward's backstories
and made a lot of foreshadowing
references to people releasing inner
things inside of them like secret powers
so I think we could get some full-on
superhero action in the finale if you're
finding me for the first time I do
Marvel and agents of shield videos every
week as soon as agents of shield goes
off the air though I'm gonna be
replacing those videos with Star Wars
videos so be sure to subscribe to get
everything and leave me suggestions for
bonus videos so let's talk about some
Howling Commandos and flashbacks here
are my top 5 moments careful for
spoilers from the episode if you haven't
seen it yet but number 5 Garrett
recruits Ward for Hydra we finally found
out how Garrett rescued Ward from a bad
situation I actually thought he killed
his brother in that house fire but more
importantly I think that he convincingly
lied about trying to kill his brother I
don't know why shield agents would have
to break into juvie like they were
breaking him out of prison or something
maybe Garrett was just too lazy to do
all the necessary paperwork so now we'll
just break him out the funniest part was
when Garrett dumped him in the middle of
nowhere Wyoming and told him to survive
it reminded me of when How I Met Your
Mother showed robin scherbatsky's sweet
16 flashback she's played by Cobie
Smulders aka Maria Hill she got dropped
out of the helicopter and was forced to
fight off packs of rabid wolves and
horny minors so does that imply in a
meta way that Maria Hill is a much
bigger badass than Ward yes I kind of
think it does we did see his dog in the
crosshairs at the end - I think they
just wanted to leave the possibility of
Ward getting a Redemption arc and if
they had shown him straight up killing
the dog it would have been a much harder
sell after the finale and when you
really think about it he didn't kill
Fitz and Simmons he just dropped them in
a glass container out of a giant
aircraft you know loki style from
Avengers if only they had Thor's hammer
to break their way out to number 4
howling commando Antiques Roadshow this
was definitely the most fun scene aside
from maybe them trying to break into
cyber tech with false identities and
costumes in case you forgot though
triplets grandfather was a howling
commando and technically you know so is
Nick Fury but they're playing it fast
and loose with the timelines I'm
thinking Nick Fury was probably one
during the 60s and 70s I don't think
that he fought with triplets grandfather
here's the list of special items that I
heard Coulson geeking out over a
handheld hypno-beam a transistorized
blaster gun the joy buzzer EMP and the
grappling gun that they used to zipline
onto the train in the first Captain
America movie they actually use that in
the episode just based on that one item
I would bet the triplets grandfather was
a howling commando around the same time
Captain America was going on you know
like post-world War two don't be
surprised though if we get a lot more
references to Coulson's love of
memorabilia in the future I could
totally see Coulson playing with his
toys you know like in space balls when
no one's looking it'd be so hilarious
just pew pew pew pew but that's actually
one of the big flashbacks that we have
not gotten yet that I really want to see
like Coulson flashing back to whenever
Nick Fury took him under his wing number
three
Garrett was the first Deathlok in case
you didn't know the comic book version
of the character is a cyborg not a
Deathlok cyborg like on the show but we
did get a peek at Garrett's metal
plating last week he's basically on the
edge of death you know just because his
body is so far gone whenever he started
the program this was basically the big
plan reveal and Coulson did kind of
figure it out with his chart porn but
Garrett was the one that explained it
explicitly you know he needs the serum
to live he's only got one to two months
I was really happy when they gave us
that flash back to Garrett talking about
how he joined Hydra you know she'll
basically took a dump on him and so he's
just out for revenge I keep watching
Raina more and more closely too because
as she learns what Garrett is really
after she and Ward start to distance
themselves just a little bit for him at
least in an emotional sense
I really do sense of reckoning coming if
it weren't plainly obvious already that
Coulson is always gonna win in the end I
mean he survived death so how could he
not be Garrett number two Raina and may
foreshadow transformations and releasing
inner power this is all about Skye
everyone is wondering WTF is up with her
DNA Raina is coming at it from a
metahuman perspective you know all that
talk about what's on the inside
revealing itself is just a clear
indicator that Skye and Raina are going
to either morph into aliens or
superhumans during the finale something
is going to happen someone will go
through a physical transformation
because guy is 100% alien and looks
human there are only a couple
possibilities that I think she could be
either she's a straight-up frost giant
runt just like Loki was
you know a lot monsters Reyna mentioned
or she's Cree or she's a scroll or super
scroll they're the ones that change form
either way both her parents were aliens
so she isn't half anything she is 100%
Cree super scroll or frost giant I do
feel like super scroll is the best
explanation given all the data that we
know right now so let's go with that
your friendly neighborhood scroll and my
number one WTF moment
Garrett takes the serum glowy skin
equals not good for Team Coulson we saw
him punch Coulson across the room in the
teaser for the next episode so I'm
guessing that he's healed and super
strong and probably super crazy
I did expect him to manifest some sort
of physical deformity but the minute
Raina produced that vial I knew there
was no way Garrett was not going to take
it himself there was only one of them
left and all that he really cares about
is himself so why wouldn't he take it
and big question why would Raina
give it to him if she knew that the
answer is is because she's curious and
she wants to see what comes out from the
inside you know just like with Skye she
kept looking at her own hand like she
was also hiding something special like
she's either a metahuman or she's an
alien or Scroll in disguise or
something's going on with her so what
I'm expecting to happen in the finale is
that they will show us but Skye is like
she will go through a physical
transformation but they'll leave the
explanation of what that is and her
heritage for season two it feels a lot
like a willow Buffy thing where she
developed her witch powers over the
course of a few seasons you know not all
at once but now it's your turn let me
know in the comments below what was your
biggest WTF moment and do you think the
ward killed that dog we did not hear a
gun go off I don't think he killed him
overall this episode was totally back up
to a - status I loved Murray Hill last
week but this episode really went a long
way to deepening the sky blue alien plot
and right now that's really the only
plot I care about I totally expect Brett
Dalton to be on the show in season two
and even if everyone hates him he'll
totally be back on Team Coulson so
that's going on in the background Bill
Paxton on the other side of the fence
has been a lot of fun to watch at times
but I feel like for him this episode was
just purgatory before he gets to be that
full-on super villain in the finale you
know he was amazing as a dirtbag SHIELD
agent and then as an Hydra agent
but in this episode it was mostly him
hobbling around being taken up by joy
buzzer
Pease he was literally a felishj bag of
fail until they took that serum I really
do hate it when characters are in limbo
you know either be a man or be a
Superman don't sit on the fence is just
super boring based on all that blue
Alien may bottled rage Ward and Rayna
turncoat foreshadowing I feel like the
final battle will pretty much beat all
of the main characters versus Garrett
Deathlok - but they do have to fix that
detonator issue in his brain before he
can help out
remember samuel l.jackson is back - so
he is definitely gonna kick some ass
there's no time I ever see him on screen
where I don't think he won't be kicking
ass I know a lot of you two have been
asking me about agents of shield being
renewed for season two
it hasn't officially been renewed but
essentially it kind of is what they're
doing is waiting to announce season two
to time it with their announcement for
the agent Carter TV show and that's
pretty much a go so they're gonna
announce both those shows at the same
time because they're both gonna be ABC
shows right now in Hollywood all the
studios are announcing which shows are
getting renewed and which pilots are
going to series for instance the flash
TV show at the CW it's pretty much
guaranteed but we'll also know about
that officially in the next week or so
so if there's anything big from the
episode that you thought I'd left out of
the video just write it below in the
comments and let me know what do you
think that sky is remember whatever that
is
it has to be 100% alien hint hint super
scroll and remember next week is the
finale so be sure to subscribe to get my
video and as soon as agents of shield
goes away I'm just replacing all of my
shield videos with Star Wars videos so
leave me suggestions for what you want
those to be about right now click here
to get my breakdown to the Gotham
trailer it's gonna be the Batman prequel
show and click here to get last week's
agents of shield thank you so much for
watching I'll see you tomorrow high
fives